Dave my husband and I are starting on
our debt snowball we estimate we can
finish it in two and a half years I'm
concerned about the credit card debt as
the interest rates around seventeen
percent would it be wise to take out a
personal one which would bear an
interest rate of about 5% to pay off the
credit card and work that snowball with
a lower interest rate that you can you
can't so let's pretend I'll just make up
some numbers you dropped it from
seventeen to five so he dropped it
twelve and let's say you had $10,000 in
credit card debt
that'd be 1,200 ollars a year you would
save except that you're paying off the
credit card debt during this two years
while we're doing this so you're not
gonna save twelve hundred ollars a year
you're probably going to save an average
or more like six hundred dollars a year
so we're talking about a thousand
dollars that you say by doing this which
is nice if you send me a thousand
dollars I'll take it nothing wrong with
a thousand dollars but a thousand
dollars doesn't solve a ten thousand
dollar credit card problem what solves a
ten thousand order credit card problem
is you being pissed off about being in
debt and sacrificing everything and
living on beans and rice rice and beans
to start paying the debt off at a
thousand two thousand dollars a month in
other words if a thousand out of ten
thousand is the scenario and I just made
up the principal amount cuz you didn't
give that to me which is fine but it's
it's usually works out about this way
about ten percent of you getting out of
debt is having a lower interest rate
about 90 percent is you in other words
you are the secret sauce my man you are
the secret sauce you are the meat the
pickles the onions and the bread the
interest rates just the wrapper it's
just the wrapper you are the hamburger
you're the secret sauce you're the one
that does this you're the answer to the
equation if interest rates were the
answer everybody would figure out a way
to borrow their way out of debt and you
can't do that so nothing wrong with
getting a lower interest rate what
happens too often if I don't frame the
narrative this way is that people feel
like when they got a lower interest rate
that they did something and then they
change any of their habits they don't
tighten their belt they keep spending
like they're in Congress and but I got a
lower interest rate it didn't work well
of course it didn't work because the
problem was not interest rate the
problem was you and so you are the
solution and take the thousand bucks
it'll be nice okay that's fine take a
lower interest rate but don't let that
feel like you've checked the box that
says I did something you check the box
that says I did almost nothing now it's
still up to me that's the box you
checked and that's okay it's okay you
can do almost nothing and then you go
fix it that's cool
hey thank you for the question man it's
a good question it comes up often over
the last thirty years of doing this